the chatelier's principle says that if a
stress is applied to a reaction mixture
at equilibrium the net reaction goes in
the direction that relieves the stress
one possible stress that we could do is
to change the volume on a reaction at
equilibrium let's say we have a
hypothetical reaction where solid a
which is symbolized by red in our
particular diagram turns into solid b
which is symbolized by blue and also c
which is a gas and c will be symbolized
by white spheres
the equilibrium constant kc for this
reaction is equal to 0.4 at 25 degrees
celsius the first particular diagram
shows the reaction at equilibrium and we
can see there's some solid a and some
solid b at the bottom of the container
and there's also some gaseous particles
of c
let's introduce a stress to our reaction
mixture at equilibrium let's decrease
the volume of the container so looking
from the first particular diagram to the
second we can see there's been a
decrease in the volume of the container
that's going to cause an increase in the
pressure because pressure comes from
these gas particles slamming into the
sides of the container and if we
decrease the volume now there's less
distance for these particles to travel
before they slam into the sides of the
container which means we increase the
collision frequency and therefore the
pressure increases
according to le chatelier's principle
the net reaction is going to go in the
direction that relieves the stress so if
the stress is increased pressure the net
reaction is going to try to move in the
direction that decreases the pressure
looking at the equation for this
hypothetical reaction the two solids
aren't really contributing to the
pressure so it's only gas c that we need
to worry about and there is one mole of
gas c on the product side and there are
zero moles of gas on the reactant side
so if the net reaction went to the right
we'd be going from zero moles of gas to
one mole of gas so going to the right
would increase the moles of gas which
would increase the pressure however
that's not what the reaction wants to do
the goal of the reaction is to relieve
the stress and therefore the reaction
wants to decrease the pressure
so the reaction is going to go to the
left to get rid of some of that gas and
decreasing the amount of gas will
decrease the pressure therefore we're
relieving the stress
if the net reaction moves to the left
we're going to lose some of our products
so we're going to decrease the amount of
c and we're going to decrease in the
amount of b and we're going to gain some
of our reactants so we're going to
increase in the amount of a and we can
see all that in the third particulate
diagram so going from the second
particular diagram to the third
particular diagram we've decreased the
amount of c we've gone from four
particles of c to only two particles of
c we've also decreased the amount of b
you can see that this blue this blue
solid has gotten smaller and we've
increased the amount of a so a is this
is this red sphere here and you can see
how it's gotten bigger from the second
particulate diagram to the third and by
going from four particles of c to only
two particles of c we've decreased the
amount of the gas and therefore we've
decreased the pressure
to better understand what happens to a
reaction mixture at equilibrium when a
stress is placed on it let's calculate
the reaction quotient q for these three
particular diagrams for the same
hypothetical reaction
the expression for the reaction quotient
q c has the same form as the equilibrium
constant expression for kc so since
solids are left out of the equilibrium
constant expression we only need to
include the concentration of the gas and
since there's a coefficient of 1 in
front of c q c is equal to the
concentration of c raised to the first
power
since there are four particles of c in
the first particulate diagram and if
each particle represents 0.1 moles of c
4 times 0.1 is equal to 0.4 moles of c
so to find the concentration of c we
take the moles and divide that by the
volume of the container which is 1.0
liter so 0.4 divided by 1.0 is equal to
0.4 molar so that's the concentration of
c in the first particular diagram we
plug that into our expression for q
so qc is equal to 0.4
and notice that kc is also equal to 0.4
so at this moment in time qc is equal to
kc which tells us the reaction is at
equilibrium
next we think about the stress that was
applied to the reaction at equilibrium
we decreased the volume and if we look
at the volumes here we're going from 1.0
liters to 0.5 liters so we're decreasing
the volume by a factor of 2 which would
cause an increase in the pressure by a
factor of 2.
and changing the volume would change the
concentration so instead of 0.4 divided
by 1.0 it'd be 0.4 divided by 0.5
which is equal to 0.8 molar so the
concentration has doubled
so if we calculate q for our second
particulate diagram we plug in the
concentration of c which is 0.8 molar so
qc is equal to 0.8
k is equal to 0.4 so q is not equal to k
therefore the reaction is not at
equilibrium for our second particulate
diagram so let me write in here
not
at equilibrium in this case qc
is greater than kc which tells us we
have too many products and not enough
reactants therefore the net reaction
goes to the left to get rid of some of
the products and to increase the the
amount of reactants
the net reaction keeps going to the left
until we reach equilibrium again so if
we calculate the concentration of c in
the third particular diagram here there
are only two particles so that'd be 0.2
moles
divided by a volume of 0.5 liters so 0.2
divided by 0.5 is equal to 0.4 molar so
qc is equal to 0.4 and since qc is equal
2.4 kc is still 0.4
0.4 so qc is equal to kc and we're at
equilibrium so equilibrium has been
re-established
since the reaction is at equilibrium in
the third particular diagram the net
reaction stops going to the left and the
concentration of c remains constant
let's apply what we've learned to
another reaction the synthesis of
ammonia from nitrogen gas and hydrogen
gas
if we have a mixture of these gases at
equilibrium and we introduce the stress
to the system like a decrease in volume
the decrease in the volume of the
container would cause an increase in the
pressure and according to le chatelier's
principle the net reaction is going to
go in the direction that relieves the
stress that was placed on the system so
if the stress is increased pressure the
net reaction says i want to move the
direction that decreases that pressure
so the net reaction moves to the right
because there are four moles of gas on
the left and only two moles of gas on
the right and by moving to the right
that goes from 4 moles of gas to 2 moles
of gas which decreases the amount of gas
and causes a decrease in the pressure
if we had a mixture of these gases at
equilibrium and we increased the volume
an increase in the volume would cause a
decrease in the pressure so the stress
this time is decreased pressure to
relieve the stress the net reaction
wants to move in the direction that
increases the pressure therefore the net
reaction is going to move to the left
because if it moves to the left we're
going from two moles of gas on the right
to four moles of gas on the left so
that's an increase in the moles of gas
and an increase in the amount of gas
causes an increase in the pressure
now let's see what happens when we have
equal amounts of moles of gas on both
sides of the equation for example for
the hypothetical reaction where gas a
turns into gas b there's one mole of gas
on the reactant side and there's one
mole of gas on the product side and
let's use particulate diagrams and
reaction quotients to understand what's
going on here so for our first
particular diagram here's the qc
expression it's equal to the
concentration of b to the first power
divided by the concentration of a to the
first power and the concentration of b
since b is blue there's two
blue spheres in this first particulate
diagram so 2 times 0.1 moles is 0.2
moles of blue divided by a volume of 1
liter therefore the concentration of b
is equal to 0.2
the concentration of a would also be
equal to 0.2 molar because there's two
particles of a in here so 0.2 divided by
0.2 is equal to 1
and since k is equal to 1 for this
reaction kc is equal to 1 at 25 degrees
celsius
qc is equal to kc at this moment in time
therefore the reaction is at equilibrium
in this first particular diagram if we
introduce a stress to our system at
equilibrium let's decrease the volume by
a factor of two so we're going from one
one liter to point five liters that's
going to increase the pressure by a
factor of 2 and it's also going to
double the concentrations
so the concentration of b is now 0.4
molar and the concentration of a is also
0.4 molar so 0.4 divided by 0.4 is equal
to 1.
so qc is still equal to kc the reaction
is still at equilibrium
since changing the volume didn't change
the value for q q c is still equal to k
c and since there's no change there's no
net reaction to the left and there's no
net reaction to the right therefore
changing the volume on a reaction at
equilibrium when there are equal amounts
of moles of gas on both sides has no
effect
on the composition of the equilibrium
mixture let's go back to the reaction
for the synthesis of ammonia gas from
nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas and let's
say this reaction is at equilibrium and
we add in some helium gas to the
reaction mixture at equilibrium helium
is an inert gas which means it doesn't
react with any of the gases that we have
present it's tempting to say adding this
inert gas would increase the total
pressure
and therefore the net reaction would
shift to the right to get rid of that
increased pressure however notice that
helium is not a part of the expression
for qc
and therefore after you add it you're
not actually changing any of these
concentrations and so qc is still equal
to kc after the addition of helium and
since qc is equal to kc the reaction is
still at equilibrium and there's no
shift either direction therefore adding
an inert gas to a reaction mixture at
equilibrium has no effect on the
composition of the reaction mixture